it's also millions and millions of
people not only millions of of people in
Israel millions of Jews throughout the
world but millions of not millions of
non-jews who see in the story of Israel
um
a parable for Humanity because if the
Jewish people
can overcome the most Dreadful odds in
history you can come back from the dead
can afford this river between
Annihilation and salvation
uh and build this remarkable state then
there's hope for all of humanity
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the twice and future Prime Minister of
the state of Israel and author of the
new book Bibi my story prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu welcome to the Reuben
report
good to be with you please you know I
have to say I've I've watched you
obviously on television a million
interviews over the years speaking at
the UN all kinds of things and one of
the things that I always think when
you're speaking or any advocate for
Israel is why don't they show more maps
just show a map of the Middle East and
the size of Israel versus you know the
entire region and everything else and
then I get a copy of your book and we're
going to show you the full thing on
screen but I'm going to hold it up for
just a moment that's exactly how the
book begins right the opening flap right
there just to give a little context to
the size and I thought that would be an
interesting way to uh start the
conversation wait a minute you have to
do something open that book yes
um put your finger on Israel so they get
a feeling for the Arab world this is
Israel right yes exactly yeah and and
don't even begin to Encompass the Arab
world or Iran in this in these two flaps
so that's that's my two cents worth of
proportion yeah well I thought it was a
nice way to start because basically when
people look at most maps of the world
you you can't even fit one letter of the
word Israel on Israel itself and I feel
like if people understood that a little
bit more maybe they'd be perhaps a
little bit Kinder is that just naivete
as someone that's been defending Israel
for you know 60 plus years well it's a
social thinking but yeah I guess when
people are exposed to the facts which
many are not uh yeah they see it
differently and they they realize that
Israel is a tiny country
but it's a gigantic country because even
though we constitute uh less than one
tenth one-tenth of one percent of the
world's population we have been
consistently ranked in the decade uh
that I led the country between 2010 and
220 uh as the eighth most powerful uh uh
country in the world which is uh is kind
of unbelievable I mean when you think of
it uh and that that is I suppose not
only you can explain that rationally but
I think it's a miracle of faith and
resolution Israel because of the
resolution the resolve of its citizens a
genius of its people has become the
Juggernaut
um Innovation nation in the world and we
have uh we've just crossed in GDP we've
crossed Japan
France Britain
um and Germany GDP per capita and
remember when I I described this in my
book when we began the economic
Revolution uh towards free markets away
from socialism we were basically the
last place in Western Europe and now
we're pretty much in first place and
we're we're going to catch up with the
United States that's
a personal Quest I'm not saying that
since but we'll catch up with the United
States
so as I described in the opening you are
the twice and future Prime Minister of
Israel as as we speak right now you're
in the midst of of forming this
Coalition you have the mandate to do it
you've done this a couple times before
but Israel seems to have elections every
what six months or so uh are you
confident that you're gonna pull this
thing together I mean this one looks a
little more solid I guess than the last
few right
yeah well we have first of all this is a
sixth time I'm forming a government and
uh I've been Israel's longest serving
prime minister and I describe my
travails and triumphs in the in the
course of that very long career within a
year I'll be the longest serving elected
leader of a democracy in over half a
century of any place in the world but
somebody put me on Note the other day
gave me a note and he said well you
should know that there are leaders
who've come back from political death uh
Churchill want an example
but this fellow told me I've checked
when was the last time somebody came
back from political death twice and he
said that happened three quarters of a
century ago so I don't uh I don't
belittle the task before me but I think
after a succession of uh un indecisive
elections in the formation of a peculiar
government that was brought down after a
year we now have a solid majority a
coherent majority who form a center
right and right government coherent in
policy that will I think take Israel and
the Middle East to Fantastic places
contrary to the
left-leaning Press will get more peace
treaties
perhaps and the Arab Israeli conflict
altogether not the Palestinian Israeli
conflict the conflict of the Arab world
which is 99 times the size of the
Palestinians and block Iran and develop
technologies that will stupefy the world
and service all of all of humanity these
are some of the goals that I have and I
think that Within Reach I guess I think
it'll be more stable and I think it'll
be successful you mentioned a center
right or right Coalition can you sort of
compare how that's different than say an
American right I know you're a student
of American politics as well but for you
guys the right is it's a little bit
different just by the nature of the the
demographics and everything else
well I think the uh first of all it's a
parliamentary system so we have to
Cobble together a coalition it's not as
if the prime minister is elected by the
popular vote like the president he can
choose his cabinet and so on this is not
do you get jealous of our two-party
system when you're in the midst of
trying to Cobble this thing together
they're wildly so envious to the roots
of my being but because cobbling
together Coalition is like uh you know
you're familiar with the Rubik's Cube
you know yeah of course turn one and
then it you have to turn the other one
and it matches and you turn it and you
think you got it and then the last piece
doesn't match you have to start all over
again that's more or less what I've been
doing over the last few weeks but I
think I think I'm getting there I'm this
is not Reuben's Cube this is Rubik's
Cube I'm Rubik so at the end I have to
be rubric or there's no government uh
there will be a government uh so uh the
first thing is you have to Cobble
together a coalition uh that is a
majority in the members of the
parliament our Congress if you will and
they choose the Prime Minister and
obviously if we put it together they'll
they'll choose me that's the first uh
change the Second Chance is because you
have a multi multiplicity of parties you
don't have two parties you have I don't
know 12 parties in the knusts and
something like that uh and uh the third
thing is that
um the right in Israel
is first of all premised the differences
between left and right our premise first
of all in the intensity that you put on
the question of security security is the
number one issue in Israeli elections
the economy is a second uh
sometimes a distance second uh and the
uh I would say the uh intensity of
identification with the Jewish State
and how you protect it is really what
guides uh guides Israeli elections and
that's what brought me to office here
because the outgoing government to
Cobble together their coalition
uh basically made a pact with uh a party
and our party that
identifies with the Muslim Brotherhood
the Muslim brother
to recognize the Jewish State and wants
to dissolve a Jewish State now obviously
the outgoing Coalition didn't want to
dissolve the Jewish state but they made
themselves Hostage to uh a party that
does in order to stay in power that
didn't last long and it was brought down
and now uh I assure you that's not going
to be repeated by the way many Arabs
support me many Arabs vote for the likud
and Arabs have served in the liquid and
conserve in any government in the future
but the the issue is not the ethnicity
of the the voters or the ministers or
the president members it's their
ideology and once the ideology to which
unfortunately some Jews subscribe to
Jewish knesset members that Israel
should be dissolved destroyed eliminated
uh obviously that didn't do well with
the voters so here we are we have uh we
have a way to correct this
how do you balance some of the the
tensions between the the secular people
and the more religious people as someone
that's going to be prime minister for
everybody you've obviously done this a
couple times before uh obviously very
successfully but that that's one of the
the sort of fissures in Israeli Society
uh what you do in any uh democracy is
you compromise you make compromises
there are things you don't compromise
about on Israel's existence on security
I don't compromise and if I have to
stand up and go to a joint session of
Congress uh to challenge
um a person I respected but disagreed
with the President Obama uh he wanted to
pass this uh and did actually this uh
dangerous Iran nuclear deal which would
pave Iraq's path with gold to a nuclear
Arsenal well I thought I had no choice I
have to go and take a stand and gave a
speech there which I described in detail
uh so there are things you don't
compromise about but in the life and
political life and democracies that's
what you constantly do you either come
to an agreement with the opposing views
and if you don't come to an agreement
you bring it to uh to the vote uh and
often you
um you come to an agreement by arriving
at some kind of balance between opposing
views and that's being done every day
you do it in the American Congress you
do it in the Israeli knessel
so as someone that's uh you're you're
basically the same age as the country
within within a couple years uh and you
you were born in a time when you know
the country was trying to come together
was obviously not powerful a couple
couple Miracles basically to even come
into existence as a nation versus now
where there's a military might and an
economic power that you're talking about
how different is that for the Israeli
psyche or even just even just for you as
the leader of the country knowing what
the country was 50 years ago compared to
where it's at in 2022. well
you know I describe the roots of my
views I'm very much influenced by my
father was a great historian of the
Jewish people but what he taught me was
that there is no finality in the life of
Nations nations of combinations of God
and the Jewish people are perhaps unique
in the fact that having lost our country
having lost our state having been
dispersed to the Far Corners of the
earth we actually came back and
reconstituted our national life uh in in
our home and our tiny Homeland but Aroma
and the fact that we did that was I
would say the uh the mission of
restoring Jewish nationhood and Jewish
Independence in the land of Israel was
the task that informed my grandfather
and my father uh in founding and helping
found the state the test that uh that I
inherited was to secure the future the
the prosperity and especially the
security and permanence of this state
because it's not guaranteed well what
guarantees what guarantees
um the life of states in a turbulent
World which is often cruel well you know
for some people uh on the left they
think that if you're moral and if you
were put up a nice facade to the world a
compliant facade then history will
protect you um in fact they often quote
Martin Luther King who said that
the Ark of History bends towards Justice
maybe so but it is a very brittle Arc
and it could break under the pounding of
the darkest forces the totalitarian
dictatorial and uh and ideological
forces that are opposed to the very idea
of freedom and Justice so and history
doesn't favor morality it favors
strength that's what it does that's why
Genghis Khan could conquer conquer the
world and hold his uh you know and hold
down that Empire could hold on for a
century include an enormous subjugation
the Romans whatever you think of them
held it for many many more centuries who
just sheer power sheer coercion and
power and there's a guarantee that our
free civilization does history guarantee
that our free civilization would triumph
over totalitarian forces and the answer
is categorically not if they can amass
greater economic military and political
power especially economic and military
power and they'll overcome you if you
don't have enough counter prevailing
Force Israel being a tiny country had to
be enormously more powerful given that
it was surrounded at first by hundreds
of millions of Arabs who wanted to
destroy it and Lately by about 100
million Iranians who don't want to
destroy it but are governed by these
theological Thugs who do and openly
declare death to Israel and by the way
death to America too but they're
building atomic bombs that's what they
seek to do to destroy Israel so you need
to be very very strong I devoted my life
as I described in my book to uh Empower
Israel not to not to subjugate others
but to defend itself from others and to
make sure that nobody could destroy the
one and only Jewish State once it was
reconstituted after thousands of years
the one thing that
and all Israelis understood that they
understood that we have to have a strong
Army the first Prime Minister David
benguel invested an enormous effort to
build such an army but I came to the
conclusion that it couldn't be sustained
it couldn't be sustained because F-35
fighter aircraft submarines drones cyber
intelligence and so on they have one
common quality they cost money a lot of
money and if you have a socialist
economy you're not going to be able to
pay for defense typically the way
Israelis thought about it well the
government will produce the money how
will they produce the money tax the rich
tax the rich well they're not first of
all they're not enough rich people in a
socialist economy and secondly those who
are will move to other places when you
over tax them I came with a radical idea
which I described in my book that
there's a thing called free markets
capitalism
and that's the way we generate both a
better life for our people
a higher income a higher distribution of
income compared to the the Socialist
leading people were thinking but also it
gives us the wherewithal to fund our
military and therefore I initiated uh a
free market revolution in Israel that
made Israel into this Juggernaut this
pre-market Juggernaut of the Innovation
nation that can compete with any country
in the world that in fact does and that
changed Israel it gave it the economic
power to have to have military power and
the combination of the two gave us
diplomatic power and that is what can
guarantee our future not forever
I don't know of anything that protects
you forever but for the coming decades
and that's what I intend to to nurture
further in uh in the coming years and my
next 10 years prime minister so I want
to get back to the economic stuff
because I think it's super interesting
that you guys went in essence from a
socialist Nation to a capitalist nation
and then an economic virus where in the
United States we seem to be doing some
version of the reverse of that at least
at least at the moment hopefully not for
too long but on some of the security
stuff you just mentioned you were sort
of way ahead when it came to like the
Gaza withdrawal of 20 some odd years ago
you were not for it when when Sharon did
it and you said it would not bring peace
clearly that was proven correct when you
talk to your Lefty counterparts or if
they if they're willing to talk to you
do they still believe that oh if we just
give away enough land that actually that
would provide peace I mean are there
really thought leaders on the left that
believe those things at this point
or or is it just posturing well no I
think some of them believe it but they
also avoid talking about it because
because the most of the public doesn't
accept it why because we tried it so we
left we vacated Lebanon the the argument
was you give territory you get peace
territory for peace okay we left Lebanon
and that territory was taken over by
proxies of uh Iran Hezbollah who fired
ten thousand Rockets since then into
Israel we left Gaza uh again with the
hope that this would create peace and if
this was taken over by another proxy of
Iran or a close uh uh close Ally of Iran
Hamas and they fired 10 000 Rockets into
Israel and if you say all right so let's
leave Judea Samaria which is uh the
Heartland the the biblical Heartland of
Israel and what and it envelops uh
Jerusalem and Surround is within
spitting distance of Tel Aviv uh just
leave and Israel by the way would become
10 miles wide with it exactly
and just shut your eyes hope for the
best and hope that what happened in
Lebanon with Hezbollah what happened in
uh in Gaza with Hamas doesn't occur uh
in Judea Samara in the West Bank okay uh
people can't buy that now because we've
tried it you know fool me once shame on
me for me twice you know that uh and
that's people are not going to do that
so you asked do they believe it they
probably cling to it as a religious uh
you know sort of a religious
religious belief that they don't about
it right away but politically this
simply didn't come up in the previous
elections it just wasn't an issue not at
all uh and uh you know the issue was me
I was the issue they basically said you
know the issue wasn't Israel's uh
security not the idea of creating a
Palestinian state which would be an
armed Palestinian State uh committed to
our destruction people didn't by that
right it would also be two states
wouldn't it wouldn't wouldn't in essence
there would be two I mean it would it
would really be a three-state solution
not a two-state solution because Gaza
and the West Bank obviously are not
connected people don't really understand
that has already been shown away and
it's a it's effectively an independent
states surrounded by Israel and Egypt
but it's an independent state well what
do they do with it you know they build
tunnels they know they're Terror tunnels
in order to penetrate it so build
Rockets they didn't do a damn thing for
their people the Hamas you know they
execute that's what they do they shoot
them in the back of the neck if they
dare utter dissent they uh uh you know
this they abuse they're women they uh
abuse gays and so on but that doesn't
prevent the international left from
talking about human rights talking about
Israel and human rights and not about
these these Thugs who do these horrible
things to their own people just as until
recently they didn't talk about Iran
until those Brave and so ordinarily
Brave women went out in the street and
this created a united front of left and
right that finally sees the true nature
of this horrible regime in in Tehran
that hasn't yet happened to the
Palestinians but but you can look what
do you think is the difference between
the Iranian regime and the the
Palestinian regime in Gaza the answer is
nothing it's only smaller and less
well-armed that's the only difference
but in terms of in terms of violating
the rights of Palestinians you know men
and women and and everybody else they're
horrible horrible people so you can't
get peace if you talk about peace the
reason we haven't had peace with the
Palestinians
uh is because the Palestinians don't
want peace I mean they've been led by
leaders who are committed to Israel's
Destruction for now for a century before
the existence of Israel and since the
existence of Israel and they say they
want peace but without Israel they say
they want a state but it's not a state
next to Israel it's a state instead of
Israel so
one of the things that happened as a
result of what I just described is that
people said you have to first have peace
with the Palestinians before we can have
peace with the broader Arab world
remember the Palestinians are one to two
percent of the Arab world both in land
mass and in population
uh but the regular thinking the
prevailing thinking and the you know and
the foreign policy Elites and the in the
foreign Ministry chancellories of the
world you have to have peace with the
Palestinians or you won't have peace
between Israel and the rest of the Arab
world and I thought did it the other way
not only did I do it the other way we
waited for 25 years a quarter of a
century that way we didn't get anywhere
we couldn't and we'd wait another half
century maybe another Century I said no
we're going around we're going to around
that and we'll go directly to the Arab
world and as a result of the rise of
Israeli power because of our the the
revolution that uh that we LED Island to
make Israel a free market economy which
bolstered our military and Intel and
cyber capability we became very valuable
to other countries valuable in civilian
technology which could better the lives
of their Citizen and valuable in terms
of uh offering security help of fending
off a Common Thread like Iran so what
happened was and I could see this
happening uh and I nurtured it and it to
happen
is that Arab states began to look at us
not as an enemy
but as their indispensable Ally in
defending off Iranian aggression which
would subjugate them to and bringing a
better life for their citizens and that
view was I would say was dramatized
brought to a head in that speech that I
made in Congress challenging President
Obama's
deal with Iran while I was giving that
speech
in real time we got phone calls from
Gulf States
in which the representatives of these
governments were saying we can't believe
what your prime minister is doing
we can't believe he's standing up the
way is because he's really standing up
for us we don't have you know an
exemption to do that but that led to
clandestine meetings I'm talking about
2015.
2015. and that led to secret beatings uh
with the golf leaders and that laid the
foundation for the Abraham Accords that
turned things upside down if the idea
was that you make peace inside out from
the Palestinians to the broader Arab
world I said well
maybe so if the Palestinians want to
come but we're not going to wait for
them and I said we're going to make an
inside outside in we'll go to the Arab
states uh and finally we'll you know
we'll double back to the Palestinians
but that is uh that produced four
historic peace Accord with the help of
President Trump and his team the Abraham
Accords peace with the United Arab
Emirates peace with uh Bahrain peace
with the Morocco and peace with Sudan
and I've actually come to this podcast
to this uh discussion of ours
um right from the celebrating the
Independence Day of the Emirates uh here
in Tel Aviv
if you said two years ago yeah
you know if you said two years ago this
would happen people would think you're
crazy I didn't think it was crazy I knew
it would happen if you told me that
hundreds of thousands of Israelis would
be flying over the Skies of Saudi Arabia
uh and and dancing in the streets with
the emiratis uh in Abu Dhabi and in
Dubai you'd say this is crazy but it's
not crazy it's happening and this is the
path to peace that I intend to pursue
with much greater even greater forever
not much greater for but greater forever
and great opportunity uh in the coming
years
how much of the uh the mishigas there's
a word for you of uh the Middle East is
just uh people not really understanding
the history I've heard you talk about
the history of Israel many many times
but people not understanding that when
you talk about Judea and Samaria which
we now know as the West Bank Judea Jews
used to live there Bethlehem that's
where Jesus lived that this is not a
place that Jews are foreign from that
people simply don't understand the basic
history of the land
well you know in the modern world uh if
you have you're lucky if uh your
historical memory goes back to breakfast
yeah but in our case I mean people
you're right they don't know the facts
they think we're the uh belgians in the
Congo or the Dutch in Indonesia or some
British Colonials I don't know in some
other part of uh Africa and so on and of
course this is not the case as you say
Jews came from Judea uh King David uh
it's been our homeland for 3 500 years
3000 years ago King David proclaimed
Jerusalem as our Capital the events
described in the Bible uh occurred for a
period of about two thousand years
actually less but about 1500 years
until the birth of uh just before the
birth of Christianity now where did that
happen where did Jesus turn over the uh
the tables of the money changers it
wasn't in a temple in Tibet you know all
right next to joburg in South Africa it
happened right there in Jerusalem uh and
what did what language did Jesus Jesus
speak he spoke Hebrew and he spoke
Aramaic he probably wrote in Hebrew and
so on his name is a Hebrew name he was a
Jewish rabbi from the Galilee so there's
an attempt to erase the first roughly 2
000 years of Jewish history it didn't
exist the Jews were not there well we
were in the original uh natives of the
land and actually we were dispossessed
you know all these conquerors people who
conquered us the Romans and before them
the Greeks and after the byzantines and
so on none of them displaced us actually
the displacement of the Jews from their
Homeland took place uh in greater
numbers and in significant numbers
after the Arabs conquered the land in
the 7th Century okay so it's not the
Arabs were the ones who uh who
expropriated the land from the Jews and
the Jews didn't expropriated from the
Arabs well that happens so what you're
gonna go back uh now 1300 years to the
7th Century the Arabs came in they lived
there it's their land no that's not what
happened
the Arab Conquest didn't populate the
land they didn't build new cities except
one communities one one because
everything else was left Barren and they
too were displaced by other
conquerors other mom looks the
Ottomans the British at the end I don't
I won't get into that but a succession
of Empires govern this land
and it was nothing it wasn't the
homeland of anyone except the Jews who
never gave up the dream of coming back
to there and over the centuries Jews
would pray next year in Jerusalem next
year in Jerusalem and was only in the
19th century when a modern Moses emerged
from for our people his name was
Theodore or herzo he was 36 years old
and he worked for only for eight years
that's it for eight years a giant of
history and because he died young at 44.
and he said the only way to have
National salvation uh and to avoid what
he foresaw would be the Holocaust in
Europe would be for the Jewish people to
come back to their ancestral Homeland
that return that began in the latter
part of the 19th century
uh brought the land back to life and as
we were bringing it back to life there
were people living there but very few uh
but the there was a great influx that
came in as a result of the Jewish return
influx of Arabs who came into better
wages for the factories for the uh
hospitals uh for the uh Farms that the
Jews built that attracted many Arabs
they now call themselves Palestinians
they say we've been here for thousands
of years you know from the time of Jesus
no they won we had a burdened Homeland
when the Jews came here in the 19th
century no you didn't Mark Twain will
attest to that and hundreds yeah nothing
you had nothing there we came back to
our ancestral Homeland rebuilt it
accepted the our Arab neighbors but they
refused to have ours and they still
refused so if you want to understand the
Justice of the Jewish case is we never
gave up our claim to our homeland we are
the native uh owners of the land we are
the ones who have every right to live
there uh having been dispossessed from
it first of all by Arabs but we don't
want to dispossess the Arabs themselves
they're the ones who refuse to do it and
if you ask me what is the persistent
obstacle
to having an israeli-palestinian piece
as opposed to
an Israeli Arabs which we're achieving
it's the persistent Palestinian refusal
to recognize a Jewish state in any
boundary that's the problem and because
that's not going to be resolved right
away I say go to the Arab world get
these extraordinary agreements with the
Arab countries
and The Greatest Prize would be without
a doubt Saudi Arabia which would
effectively peace with Saudi Arabia
would effectively end the arab-israeli
conflict and then do your damnedest to
get the rejectionist leadership uh in
the Palestinian world uh Palestinian
Society to accept the right of the
Jewish people to have a state of their
own and then I think we can have a
solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict but I think
it's I think that's going to be the
order I had to change
um a perception that had been ingrained
in the minds of the experts and the one
mavens and you name them you know for
for close to half a century I simply
challenged it and I was the think tank
people in DC probably were not that
thrilled with you the think tank people
in Tel Aviv went through it and
basically you know I have an idea that
all think tanks and many diplomats are
all produced in a secret plant 30
kilometers west of Luxembourg and then
they're sort of sent dispatched to all
the the bureaucracies the foreign policy
bureaucracy of the world then they just
chant this thing the Palestinian
conflict is the center of the is the
core of the conflict always in the
singular in the Middle East no it's not
uh the only way you can solve it is for
Israel to become so weak that it
couldn't defend itself no it's not
there's not going to be peace with the
rest of the Arab world if you don't
solve the palestinian-israeli conflict
no it's not but you know if you vest
yourself in this nonsense for decades
it's very hard to uh very hard to uh uh
detach yourself from it and so I always
find it I always find it interesting how
how it sort of mainstreams itself in a
bizarre sense so for example you know
Rashida Talib our congresswoman in
Michigan who I have no doubt you're not
a big fan of I think maybe she was even
banned from Israel at one point you know
show every uh December she wishes Jews a
happy Hanukkah but at the same time she
doesn't want Jews living in the place
that is the story of Hanukkah does she
know about the hills probably about two
miles from you right now
happy Hanukkah you know Hanukkah was
celebrated the victory of the Brave
Maccabees against one of the conquerors
of our land uh actually 2200 years ago
roughly 2200 years ago 2 200 years ago
Jews were fighting for their freedom
against the uh basically the uh the
Celia seed Empire which was based in
Syria one of the uh uh it's named after
one of the generals of Alexander the
Great uh who actually had a positive uh
attitude towards Jews but his uh
inheritors didn't uh and uh one of them
wanted to wipe out the Jewish religion
and Jews rebelled and this rebellion led
by by brothers who each died they all
died in this battle uh finally achieved
The Liberation of the land and the
liberation of Jerusalem that's what we
celebrate the uh Hanukkah is the
liberation of Jerusalem specifically the
cleansing of the uh the Jewish temple uh
so you tell that to received I want to
hear a responsibility so were the Jews
there or not were the Palestinians the
Jews were there you know and it
amplifies the the tremendous ignorance
that you you discuss they just don't
know the Jews the Jewish people are
probably one of the oldest civilizations
are not probably are one of the two or
three oldest civilizations in history
our attachment to our uh ancestral
Homeland is unmatched uh a lot of people
are attached to their ancestral Homeland
but they're not as old as us and a lot
of them lost their ancestral Homeland
and disappeared we're the only ones who
were kicked out of it uh expel from it
and said we're going to come back and we
came back to find the odds of History
achieve this miracle build this
extraordinarily uh modern uh successful
State we respect Our Roots we respect
our neighbors
uh and we're bringing a light on to the
nation's principally by incredible
technology and yet they say you have no
right to live there you know we kicked
you out once we'll kick you out again no
you won't it won't happen whether you're
a Hamas or a Hezbollah or Iran it's not
going to happen We're not gonna let it
happen well it certainly ain't gonna
happen under your watch I I do want to
be respectful of your time because it's
late night in Israel right now and you
are in the midst of this Coalition bill
that I'm sure you have some things to do
I want to ask you just one thing
personally and and I'll post the link to
the book and people can read all about
your history and and your brother and
there's really some remarkable stuff in
there but just not on a personal note to
end uh you know you've had to go into
the fire a million times not only in the
military but domestic in terms of going
to the U.N giving these speeches the
hostility towards Israel
standing up for your country and your
your beliefs and your religion all of
those things it can't be easy it can't
be that fun I mean the amount of hate
and protests and all of this stuff and I
wonder at uh you know at your age coming
back doing this again
it's not the easiest thing in the world
but you're doing it again and you seem
as energized as ever and I where do
where does that come from within you and
did you think about not doing it I mean
when you when the last election didn't
go your way did you think okay let me
just step away or you were basically
fighting in the opposition immediately
well there was a one incident that I
described in one of my defeats because
I've had a few defeats I've had a
succession of Victories but I also had
defeats and you know that question arose
uh I had one uh uh one elections where
my party contracted to 12 seats that's
10 of the tests
for comparison we now have 32 seats in a
coalition of 64 out of 120 uh 32 LED by
my party which is by far the largest
party of the peasant
um a quarter of the seeds uh more than a
quarter
um and the Coalition that is solid
but here you go we this happened where I
contracted
to 12 seeds and I went you know I came
back from
you know meeting the the party faithful
they want too many in that evening of uh
of defeat and I said to my wife Sarah I
said uh look uh you know maybe maybe
this is the end you know we've uh you
know they eulogized me all the time
maybe this this time you're right and uh
you know why don't we just uh you know
uh get on with our family with our two
young boys and with our life and get on
with our life and she said to me baby
this is your life
don't leave it this is your purpose and
if you ask what is guided me what it
allows me to do this it's the sense of
purpose it's the fact that uh I'm
pursuing a mission and the mission which
I inherited from my uh by my grandfather
and my father and my Fallen brother is
to assure the uh the security and
permanence of the state of Israel only
by by making it strong and uh and
Powerful uh but I I think it's not only
uh my family and my wife and kids who do
boys who support me and who share this
Mission otherwise it would be impossible
to to continue but it's also millions
and millions of people not only millions
of uh of uh people in Israel millions of
Jews throughout the world but millions
of not millions of non-jews who see in
the story of Israel
um
a parable for Humanity because if the
Jewish people can overcome the most
Dreadful odds in history you can come
back from the dead can
afford this river between Annihilation
and salvation
and build this remarkable state then
there's hope for all of humanity and uh
alongside the deformation of Israel the
slander uh the vilification I have to
say there's enormous enormous respect
and admiration and sometimes adoration
in many many lands and as Israel emerges
as one of these uh Rising powers in the
world able to send Aid missions
emergency missions to dozens and dozens
of countries some of them hostile
countries to help people out of
earthquakes or hurricanes or floods you
know and people see the the true nature
of the state and when they uh they pick
up their cell phone and they understand
that a good part of that technology in
that cell phone that makes their life
different completely comes from Israel
or when you navigate in your car with
ways another Israeli product and it's
endless it goes on and on the medicine
the technology the the health the water
desalinization all these things that are
not Pie in the Sky they're not this is
real it's changing the life not only of
Israelis but of the world then there is
also a different admiration for Israel
so the life or purpose that I'm talking
about uh says that the Jewish people
have come back from the dead
and we are here and we uh we will
continue to hold The High Ground
literally
and figuratively
we are here and we're here to stay
that's my purpose and I would say to
those people who want to read my book my
story it's not really my story alone it
is my years in uh uh in a combat unit I
nearly died several times in firefights
I describe most of it within the limits
of the of
the military propriety uh and I nearly
died twice politically but it's not
merely my life it's interwoven with the
life of the Jewish people and the Jewish
state but I think that there's a larger
issue here
I live
and I can say this categorically a life
of purpose
and I think it's the if you have a
purpose in your life
and preferably if it goes beyond
yourself
it will enrich your life and make it
meaningful it's the only life worth
living and if you want to glean some
insights about that then unabashably I'm
I tell you I'm plugging my book read my
book I think
well we will link down to your book
below uh Mr Prime Minister it's cards on
the table it's it's fairly obvious to me
why the Israeli people are giving you
another crack at this and I suspect some
other peace deals and other good things
are going to come and I have to say that
I will be in Israel in May doing a few
events and you did break bread with my
good friends Jordan Peterson and Ben
Shapiro not too long ago so maybe I can
take you out for hummus something like
that
got it let's do it maybe I can take it
out the Israeli economy is doing well
it would be an honor sir uh the book is
BB my story the link is right down below
and I appreciate it Mr Prime Minister
now go now go do your Coalition thing
I'm doing exactly that you think I'm
joking but that's exactly what I'm
joking the other week
thank you so much really truly an honor
sir
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues instead of
non-stop yelling check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell